今日はねじゃあ何のために言葉を勉強するかと
[音楽]
ん
うん
[音楽]
今日はこちらしていく朝です
また言葉の勉強について話ししたいんですけれども
あーヒロチャンネルスキーであればぜひ登録してください
金のところでピックして
よしあの知らせが届けますしまた人気でまた僕と一緒に言葉を勉強してください今日は
ね
そのじゃあ何のために言葉を勉強するかと
最近のバラード号もアナ鼻あご代謝量も勉強して何のために
やはりそれはね言葉の勉強というのは一つの冒険
派遣
のいわゆる
の気概であるわけですよ
日本ではねぇまぁが永劫
前オムニえーみな外国語を勉強するっていうのは英語なんですよ
それでまあ英語でと行く回数が必要だと
これは仕事のためにとかどっかの学校に入るために取り組んのアユは東部の点数はどう
しても必要だとまぁそれはそれでもいいんですけれどもそれがいい
んだけどもやはり言葉の勉強というのは一つの新しい世界
新しい文化
だからアラビア語っていうのは相場
地図を見ればまあ膨大な面積ですねあのう
マロッコからあるですよねイラクとか
サウジアラビアまでねみんなありゃ棒で話ししてるわけですよ
そして歴史も以上に面白いと
それとまぁ僕もアラビア語を勉強したときにいろんな方迎えますよ
その pot バーンその勉強するそのにゃる
招致通りですよそれはアラビア語で英語の説明とかそう有名なアリアビア人のその作る
14世紀の有名な
その色んな国を訪ねた人でそれを見たそのそれが来国で見たことをジャンブ
その
細かく書いた人なんですけど今のところ丸まで僕にとってはも難しいすぎるんです
けれどまぁ将来そこまで
アラビアの世界についていたできるたわけですよ
あるいは英語でも歴史を読むわけですよ
アラビアの歴史とか回廊の歴とかね
だからその春アラビアの世界に入るわけでしょ
ちょっと今からはまぁいらんでしょペーション
そしてうちの猛練気でねー
そしてあもう一つ今の世界はもう皆は我々つながり出るわけですよ
でアラブに住んでいる女の人が我々のリックのためにいろんなその内容を作っている
わけですよもう
書いたりそしてアウディをも作って
そしてペンシャーイランの歴史についての26のそのエピソードがあるんですよ
そして色がそれはいつも毎日聴いてますその
古い昔のぞのぺーしゃーいらん
そして今の最近の歴史までざーなんかもなんかも聞いたりですね
言葉も勉強しているその国についても今まで何もしれなかったまあ何もというか
ほとんど知らなかったその背景でですね今いろんなも白いことべき
してはないでしょう
まあ日本ではと分にほんのりちま
東アジア
中心にしたれ市は学校で皆さんやっていると思うんですけれども
まあ我々カナダではですねやはり西ヨーロッパ英国とか
そういう嬉しい飾磨しかないまあ多いんですよね
ただ
ペン者というのはすごいんですよそしてやはり
その西洋を中心にした歴史ではその
b 社とペルシャの戦争では pc のグリー者の人たちはいいと停車は悪悪悪にん
ですよね悪いとそういうふうに我々受け取っているわけですけれどもそれじゃあ
同じイランのペ社の歴史をですねぺー者の人たちの立場から落ちる
いいランスのぺー者の言葉でそれを大きくと全然
その認識が違ってくるんですよで例えば2500年前に
ジュールス代用が
はそのシリンダーでねその彼がやはりいわゆる babylon
バビロンに入ったんですよね
侵略してキャプチャーしたっていうかそこにいろんなあの人秋冬
そして宗教があったわけでしますで彼は皆に平等というような
いえば
オーレ地というか
宣言やたわけですよこのシリンダにされ全部
迎えし昔のコロニー1500年前の
そういう文字でそれを書いたわけですよあるいはこの兄1500年前のあるいは
アーマーいえば
全500いわゆるイスラムが入るまで兄はですねぺー所では
男女平等と
女性がかなりの力が
あった様ですよね a 消費ようなことも終わり
これはの
はリンクで猫のイランの女性がその
イランの歴史に知ってが作った26の微小土の中にもそういうこともは書いてあった
わけですし
そしてはがいしやかの停車語を勉強しているから今度は英語でこれ読みやすいから a
ペルシアの歴史についても読んでるわけですよ
女
地事も書いてありますそしてそういう子はいろんな事をですいろんな側面から
に退社後で勉強したりして英語で勉強したいしてやはりある程度の
ねえその我の世界ですよねそして中ヒントっていうのは非常に大切なんですよ
あの今のえらうえらう家ではね
いわゆる昔のメソポタミアデー
選んとか住むやるとか非常に古い民族分
それがやはりイラクといい団の間なんですよで一部一時的にイランの一部でもあった
わけですよ
その辺の歴史ですねこのアラブの世界とペイしあのいわゆるイランの世界とまた
と6人の世界ですね
6人もかなり非常に影響があった理由書
ロブヨーロッパに対してもあるいは中国に対してもですね
あのいわゆる中央愛車のトルクの民族まぁ時々
モンゴル人と組み合わせてということもあったわけですけどもええそういう風
に我々皆さんならへ出るわけですよそして言葉を通じてですね
そのつながりを感じるそして我々同じその
人種同じ人類ですよね
どういう風な歴史があったと思うそして
ワームがこの制御に住んでるから西洋のうち歯科
一番大切であると
a 3
そうじゃなくてですねやはりすべてのいろんな言葉を勉強してそれぞれの立場で
それを聞いたり磯野理解してですね
我々のいろんな
21が深くなる楽しいですよ
その言葉っていうのも窓口ですよ窓口
その言葉を勉強したらその君に対して表3を感じる
いろんなつながりができるもう一つれーわねあの同じようにそのイランの方がリンクの
ためにギランの人に
ついていろんな書 no
歴史山じゃなくてそのう
内容のものですねオーディオとかいわゆる弟
文書作ってくれたり
しているわけですけれども他の立場をくらいにあでもですね同じようなこともあった
わけですよ
うくらいにあそれあのリーというに c 部位にあの街でですね
そのあるガッコそれがたまたま私はウクライヤ語の先生の1000円
教えているあの
いわゆる
言語学の
セクションですよね大学でこの生徒たちがみんな
以上にも広いくらい屋号のそのレーションをつくってくれたわけですよ
たまたまその時にうかんやの西井いいからにあの山でねー
構造があったわけですよものすごい
かなりの損害があったんですよねで彼女たちがまあ彼らが
お得もないいったわけですけれどもそのリンクのためにそういうレースを作った代わり
に僕は少しお金がその
香西じゃじゃあ洪水のその
打撃を受けた
シャア人たちにも若干お金も送ったわけですよそれのまた今写真を見せしますけど彼ら
の生活も少し
少しま良くなったような世界中に我々みんな繋がってるわけですよ
私も日本に9年間6寸なんですよ
あの日本の文化について若干
知ってるわけですよ僕は歴史について興味あります
日本語勉強した上に
昭和の記録という nhk の素晴らしい
ソ連とその時がか設定ですけれども何回も何回も聴きました
何回も何回も聴きました
まあそういうようなつながりがあったわけですよが歴史に歴史を通じたのつながり
しかしある人は日本語を勉強している理由がアニメのためにも僕あにめー全然興味ない
んですけどもまぁそれぞれの人たちがそれぞれの
入り道があるけれどもやはり言葉というのはお互いの理解
太田
外のつながりお互いの発見
まあそういうものです当駅とか投票じゃないですよね
まあそういうような話をちょっとジャパラにゃんろしたかったんです者ともう
さようなら
bea
うん
ん
んんん
[音楽]